this is a another dimension because the
Hangout is concealable it's a different
conversation than just making rifles all
handguns will eventually be available
for people to produce for themselves and
to do in the privacy of their own homes
gun control can never die because it
lives in the hearts of men no gun
control is not dead it's on dead gun
control his own death and we just keep
killing it but it just keeps coming back
in 2012 a then 25 year old crypto
anarchist - named Cody Wilson started
defense distributed an organization
devoted to removing the barriers from
making firearms at home
the following year defense distributed
released The Liberator the first 3d
printed pistol the Liberator is a simple
single-shot 380 caliber handgun at the
time the replaceable barrels were only
considered safe for one shot five years
after the Liberator debut the
technological limitations of homemade
firearms have started disappearing the
materials are cheaper and better the
machines are more precise and the
software's more advanced it's a new
reality that hasn't entirely filtered
into public debates over gun control it
outstrips people's daily experience they
don't really understand what's taking
place this is a ghost gun because now it
is very easy completely legal to make a
firearm the era in which the government
can even hope to keep a fully functional
firearm out of the hands of someone
truly determined to get one is coming to
an end now I can ship gun machines that
help you crank out 1911's in your
kitchen all day long and no one has
anything to say about because what is
there to say about by late 2014
defense distributed had raised enough
capital to begin manufacturing the ghost
gunner a small machine that uses pre
coded commands to remove metal from
unfinished firearm parts parts that when
sold by a manufacturer are legally
required to contain a serial number what
comes out of the ghost gunner is a key
component of an untraceable yet fully
functional metal firearm in late 2017
defense distributed released files that
allow the ghost gunner to mill out
unfinished metal handgun frames Wilson
says the new focus on handguns is an
important step towards the mainstreaming
of home gun
factoring a lot of people living in
urban setting like DC wouldn't consider
slinging ar-15 on their back walking
around the street but they would at
least think about whether they wanted to
have a handgun concealed and made
without anyone else's knowledge while a
3d printer assembles objects out of
layers of plastic or other materials a
milling machine like the ghost gunner
does the opposite carving a solid piece
of material based on specifications
spelled out in code defense distributed
cells the machine for just under
seventeen hundred dollars you can make a
1911 year kitchen naked in your bathtub
if you want and no one has to know about
it it's really cool and that wasn't true
last year in the way that is true thanks
to the Internet the newest generation of
homemade gun designs are approaching the
quality of store-bought firearms
[Music]
my name's Darren booth I'm a union
carpenter start getting into 3d printing
about 2014 and I was downloading
different objects from the internet
printing them out and it wasn't very
satisfied with the way they turned out
so I started getting into 3d design and
that's when I heard about The Liberator
I like to live right it's fine you know
it's only good for one shot so I thought
well what can I do to make it a little
better
this is the latest version the shetty a
p9 I make them out of PLA plastic but
they hold up well this this very gun
here has probably had over 5000 round
shot the digital files that are used to
create guns using milling machines and
3d printers are written and shared
online by hobbyist gun printers booth is
a regular of the Foss cat group and the
community worked together to create the
digital files for the shutty but it's an
open community as an open chat anybody
can go on there and just ask questions I
watched some of these groups begin like
on my own websites when I used to host
forums and IRC channels and things it's
and it's great like in our earliest days
I imagine that that would be what
victory look like there would have to be
communities taking up these projects on
their own it's an intellectual exercise
it helps you you know I'm just it's fun
to come up with new ideas exchange
information and this information
exchange is at the core of the home
manufactured gun movement the 3d printed
gun was never it's itself what we
developed what we shared online was not
the gun but it was the files that could
create the gun it's freeware for anybody
who wants to build it hopefully somebody
will make it even better
the shuddhi requires additional parts
made by third parties but those
components can be freely ordered on the
internet from unregulated vendors
[Music]
when the only thing you need to create a
gun at home is a tiny digital file and a
trip to the hardware store gun control
becomes impractical it may also be
impossible to outlaw the distribution of
digital files used for handgun
production Wilson argues that an
individual's right to create and
distribute blueprints for a gun is
protected by the First Amendment sharing
that software was a political speech act
and the software itself because it can
be changed and evaluated and understood
by humans
the software itself is speech so it's
about fighting about that that
information not about what the
information can become in 2013 the State
Department forced defense distributed to
remove the download links to the files
for The Liberator claiming they violated
the international traffic in arms
regulations or ITAR they saw these kids
you know online being like hey not only
no gun control but you know we're gonna
destroy the whole concept because the
Internet's gonna serve guns they were
looking for a way to put their own power
kind of over what we're doing the
closest thing that could come up with at
the time was the ITAR the ITAR is a set
of regulations that govern what kind of
military materials can leave the US and
go to other countries the State
Department the Justice Department say
sharing this type of information gun
files with American citizens on the
Internet is tantamount to exporting it
to foreigners and this somehow violates
a foreign affairs power of executive
joined by the Second Amendment
Foundation and the prominent appellate
attorney Alan Gura Wilson challenged the
State Department's order in spring of
2017 they petitioned the Supreme Court
for a temporary injunction that would
know the takedown order until their
lawsuit was resolved in January of 2018
the High Court declined to hear the case
sending it back to a lower court in
Texas to be argued on the merits yeah
we're gonna win our case and it doesn't
mean that we have to win it in court but
you know when in the court of public
opinion and that doesn't mean that
public obtain will agree with us
in other words the tools to build your
own firearms are already in circulation
but Wilson is trying to win legal
protections for future innovations in
the space defense distributed focus on
handguns is in part a legal strategy
based on the 2008 Supreme Court case
District of Columbia vs. Heller that
affirmed of the right to own a handgun
for self-defense
the handgun is at the center of what is
protected in the Heller decision as
everything's understood now
so whereas ar-15s may not ever be backed
up by the Supreme Court there's no way
of getting around right now the
protections that the Supreme Court gave
to the handgun and so this is the core
of the the Second Amendment Liberty as
it's currently understood now
deployables downloadable manipulatable
you can do in your garage and so it's a
kind of temptation it's an invitation to
a discourse if you will
automated off-the-books firearm
technology is a reality and there's
nothing anyone can do to change that
you